hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger sur des télés mais
telle est au tour d vous commencez déjà
limité merci isabelle attention c'est
avoue bertrand
elle est partie au géant
[Applaudissements]
attention jean louis jean luc launoy
jean luc lemoine attention elodie
gossuin malaisie au jeu en main vous
savez je garderai les deux meilleures
pour la fin donc on va faire christophe
carrière christophe carrière au japon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est joe dassin les as a décollé ces
géants nasa
[Applaudissements]
attention gilles verdez au gerb
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la tête des gens lui donnant entre
nous toucher des aides pour l'équipe
cet homme n'est pas normal où on n'a pas
j'ai mis comme toi attention tu peux les
enlever un parent il faut les garder
toute l'émotion
[Musique]
on a donné à l'aller masters il se passe
quand même quelque chose qui peut se
passer que dans cette émission là la
dame va rentrer ce soir chine l écoute
tu fais une émission formidable c'est
que d'ailleurs j'ai mis deux épis de
maïs ils ont roulé j'ai fait jouer en
vert je les fais tellement bien tout le
monde applaudit c'était un triomphe mais
vraiment un client non mais c'est énorme
oui comme ça alors là je ne me sens pas
du tout sur l'internet mais je vous le
dis là je sens qu'on va aller dans le
mur je peux raconter un truc qui
m'arrivait ah oui allez à la fin des
années 80 j'étais mariée tout ce qu'elle
peut marier avec une copine ont joué au
master mind donc avec les pions et on
fait les abris 6